[Music]
what is the most dangerous creature in
the universe here on planet earth there
are creatures that have hardly evolved
since prehistoric eras like sharks
crocodiles and snakes perfect biological
killing machines but then again the
animal kingdom is nothing when compared
to the menagerie of creatures contained
by the scp foundation so once again what
is the most dangerous creature in the
universe is it
scp-682 the damage regenerating reptile
with a hatred for all other forms of
life or is it the scarlet king or is the
broken god more deserving of that title
maybe the answer still lies elsewhere
and thankfully there is one scp in the
foundations archives that might not be
the most dangerous itself but teaches us
a very important lesson about what the
most dangerous entity truly is
this is the story of
scp-001 the spiral path an important
distinction before we go any further
scp-001 doesn't refer to a single
creature object or entity but rather a
collection of various anomalies
contained by the scp foundation it is
unclear why there are multiple files
collected under the shared designation
of
scp-001 some believe these anomalies are
some of the earliest ever contained by
the foundation encountered before they
introduce their current numbering system
there is also the theory that this is
intentional misdirection that the
multiple scp-001 files are an attempt by
the foundation to conceal secret
information about the true scp-001
anomaly sharing the name scp-001 include
the infamous aforementioned scarlet king
a powerful eldritch being intent on
ending all creation another anomalous
being with similar levels of destructive
power is the gate guardian believed to
be an angel standing at the entrance to
the garden of eden it too goes by the
name scp-001
but for the purposes of this video we
will be using scp-001 to refer to
something otherwise codenamed the spiral
path and while it is not a creature in
and of itself
scp-001 does yield one answer to that
important question what is the most
dangerous creature in the universe on
paper scp-001 does not seem to be much
and it certainly doesn't appear to be
any sort of threat as its nickname
suggests the spiral path is exactly that
located deep in a wooded area known only
as site zero
scp-002 is a gravel path in the shape of
a spiral your first thought adhering
that might be what could be so important
about a path if someone were to find
themselves walking along the spiral path
traveling clockwise around the gravel
then they will find that
nothing happens it's just a normal path
with slight inclines and declines as one
traverses it if one should walk
counterclockwise around it though then
they will begin to experience scp-001's
first anomalous effect the path will
begin to feel as if it is sloping uphill
getting steeper and steeper when they
reach the beginning of the path again a
person will still feel as if they are
walking endlessly uphill all the while
the path itself does not move or change
in form or altitude to put it simply
walking one way around scp-001
causes it to behave normally walking the
other the path does not adhere to the
laws of physics you may well be thinking
is that all on a surface level the
spiral path does appear to just be an
unmoving low threat anomaly while it may
not be as aggressive or malicious as
some of the scp foundation's rogues
gallery it is still a spatial anomaly
that defies all euclidean geometry that
might sound like small potatoes when
compared to everything the scp
foundation has faced over the years but
bear in mind if the spiral path is truly
scp-001
and the very first anomaly that the
foundation learned of then a simple path
that ignores the ordinary laws of space
and time would have been a major
discovery in the organization's earliest
days but why would they still keep the
spiral path so heavily guarded all these
years later
scp-001 is kept behind a maximum
security fence that has been constructed
all the way around the perimeter of site
zero at all times the scp foundation
keeps no less than five fully armed
members of security personnel on site to
keep watch over the spiral path and to
make sure that no one approaches it who
isn't authorized to there is a small
metal plaque too bearing an unknown
inscription on it special containment
procedures for scp-001 state that this
plaque is to be kept in good condition
and it should be immediately reported if
it shows any signs of damage a
foundation physics laboratory is also
located nearby
where research staff tirelessly conducts
scientific tests on scp-001
and its anomalous properties so there's
definitely something more to the spiral
path than a simple stroll around it
would tell you attached to scp-001's
file is an item referred to as document
001-05
written by high-ranking foundation
researcher dr everett mann any
prospective or new members of the o5
council are required to read this
document and from the events it details
learn the truth not just about the truth
of the spiral path but the truth about
the scp foundation itself dr mann begins
this file by explaining to the reader
that either he or one of the original
founders of the scp foundation must have
died and the person reading has been
appointed as a successor whether his
death was caused by an scp an operative
from another anomalous organization like
the global occult coalition or getting a
little close to the flame mann states
that old age definitely wouldn't be what
killed him he writes we took care of
that didn't we whether he means that he
and the rest of the old guard are
somehow immortal or just working for the
foundation would likely mean dying
before reaching old age is unclear but
dr mann's next statement is one that
changes the very way we view the
foundation and its entire purpose we
have never discovered an scp in the
entire history of the foundation
according to document 001-05
every instance of an anomalous creature
entity or object is entirely staged he
then goes on to describe aaron siegel a
gifted physicist that dr mann regarded
very highly i believe his name would be
there with edison einstein and hawking i
knew him very well he was and may still
be my brother the pair evidently shared
a close personal connection and it was
siegel who first discovered scp-001
during a hike aaron stumbled upon the
spiral path noticing that no matter how
far uphill he seemed to travel his
elevation never once changed only for
him to end up back at the start of the
path being a physicist siegel quickly
realized how this unassuming gravel path
did not conform to euclidean geometry
that it did not fit within the laws of
nature constructing a small wooden shack
nearby
aaron siegel began to study the
properties of the spiral path equation
after equation hours spent examining
every variable and experimenting with
his findings until something unforeseen
happened aaron created an scp a key that
had the innate ability to open any lock
nowadays that same key is still in the
foundation's possession under the
designation scp-005
slowly aaron began to bring others into
the fold trusted colleagues and other
scientific minds among them was of
course dr everett mann who was still a
medical student at harvard at the time
this brain trust a think tank composed
of only a select few they were the very
beginning the ones who founded the scp
foundation using their own fortunes and
funding from thomas carter the group
continued with sigel's experiments the
scientists had high hopes for what they
could achieve planning to change the
world for the better feeding the hungry
providing shelter to the homeless curing
the sick and even cheating death itself
in the beginning this proto foundation
started small their goals were noble but
could not realistically be achieved
overnight they tried to make items that
would improve life such as the fountain
of youth a partially sentient civil war
statue and an extremely bouncy ball
better known to the foundation today as
scp-006 scp-011
and
scp-018 respectively but then this new
foundation began to grow with more
organization and a secret facility and
with that expansion came emboldened
scientists eager to change the world the
group began working on human test
subjects volunteers and drifters that
soon became scps the spiral path was not
just a break in the fabric of reality in
a metaphorical sense it referred to the
spiraling path the newly formed
foundation itself was on every discovery
they made led to another and that to
another still until things started to go
wrong during the continuing experiments
dr mann created the scp-008 a deadly
zombie play capable of infecting anyone
with 100 percent lethality more and more
of the founders were so invested in
their projects that the results were
often nightmarish the foundation needed
help that came when thomas carter showed
their work to the military in exchange
for additional funding and personnel the
scp foundation expanded even further
becoming an international organization
and bringing in new researchers and
staff in some instances the founders
would arrange for the anomalies they had
created to be found by the new recruits
other times they would fabricate reports
changing the details about things like
scp-008
or the fountain of youth were first
discovered anything the founders said
was simply now a fact no one questioned
them even then problems still arose
founding members broke away from the scp
foundation some even creating splinter
groups that would later become infamous
groups of interest the foundation's
directive shifted now focusing on the
containment of anomalies as yet more
were created through darker means
scp-231 was taken from an orphanage dr
mann himself vivisected a small boy who
then became
scp-610 the flesh that hates and there
were more still able the blood pond and
even the hard to destroy reptile all of
them were the creation of the foundation
itself but through it all dr mann wrote
he was never afraid of the path that the
foundation was on he was never even
afraid of all the monsters and
abominations that he and the other
founders had secretly created by
studying as cp-001
what truly scared him were the anomalies
the foundation didn't create there were
some that would just appear in
containment one day even if they hadn't
been there before they would seem like
they had always been there dr mann
closes document 001-05 with the
realization that he and the other
founders simply were not in control
anymore the tale of dr mann and the
other founders of the scp foundation is
one of noble intentions that ultimately
became corrupted at first the founders
created scps that they hoped would
benefit humanity but then came the
mistakes the accidents the monsters like
scp-008
scp-610 and even scp-682
the foundation lied to the governments
and militaries of the world claiming
they'd found these scps not created them
and in return they received funding and
staff to expand allowing the scp
foundation to grow to become what it is
today dr mann posits that at this point
the foundation was no longer in control
but perhaps they never were and all this
stems back from one singular starting
point the spiral path it might be
impossible to truly know how many
anomalies and scps the foundation
created just from researching scp-001
only the o5 council will ever know
exactly how many of the founders
discoveries they themselves were
responsible for and now you know the
answer to what's the most dangerous
creature in the universe it's regular
people dabbling with something they
could never hope to fully understand
starting with the hope to change the
world only to create monsters that might
one day destroy it now go check out
scp-001 which is the real zero zero one
and
scp-001 the scarlet king for more on the
legendary scp-001
designation